this is a production of Cornell
University
so we're really fortunate Kyle and I am
students are fortunate to have a chance
to get second look at the floral
behavior both we stinky two and a half
years ago we had a chance to study
around clock for two and a half days its
production of stinky volatiles that you
visited into its name for which it's
just
so during that time there was a blog
Cornell site and people from all over
the world going in and asked where those
things what are those wires with people
doing to our flour and responded that
you're actually collecting data from it
so we thought we'd take a few minutes to
talk about open to you alright so when
when we stinky starts with escaping is
to open and the show goes on we're going
to have fishing line dangling from the
murders above plan to support this
little Valley operated vacuum pump is 94
better la palma that will allow us to
collect all tiles from the flower what's
really interesting about this is it
usually we enclose a flower they're
always always smaller than this and what
we've all has faced bad an oven bag say
that you can baby cookie it doesn't have
all types of its own we let the vault
ABS accumulate and I mean for left
or a little trap up a cigarette filter
but much smaller and so what we have
here is that it's the battery comment
that we're going to put a little filter
on ends and then hanging suspended into
the floral chamber there are a lot of
the vault has to be produced and we're
going to take snapshots every two hours
of Howard's change as the planet as the
best of the fluorescent we're doing this
in two different ways this one is
cumulative Adam publishes women run is
going to collect all tiles over time
this little soap engineer called a
solid-phase microextraction fiber for
speeding it has a little piece of
essentially fishing line that also gets
exposed in the chamber of the
inflorescence and ed soares the vault
how sponsor then we can use chemical
analysis to just strip those balls off
and separate them into their component
pizza will be posting those data on the
cornell site for everybody to see and
then what we're going to do has been
taking these chemical measurements were
also be taking measurements of
temperature for gas
we've noticed from previous research
also two years ago last
Thermal blasts and we also want to
measure possible carpet outside
we have here is a
leticia at various faiths standards
we also have syringes that will be table
near sandwich from inside
to calculate
and you have a seat too much behind us
and so what reason for being interested
that we know from the thermal imagery
that these things really heat up just
that they're producing the largest
release of all times but the the insects
that are trafficked these flowers
experience all that at once the heat
inside the chamber the carbon dioxide is
the planet perspiring like a sprinter
and these very strong an
information-rich volatiles that flies
and beetles that effectively plan have a
lot of meaning because they are
simulating the accused emanating from a
rotting corpse so what we doing that
around the clock as the flower opens as
people come in and trying to serve tisha
sleep sneak into the corner and collect
our data and we'll be posting these data
as weak as me
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu